this is a classic example of the left if
you point out how many young people are
dying like athletes just dropping dead
on the field and and I see reports like
this regularly I mean regularly like at
least every week and this is just what
we know of and then you say well
shouldn't we just investigate whether
the vaccine has been beneficial or
harmful to young people young meaning
under 50. that's a pretty large young
group shouldn't we just investigate oh
you're an anti-vaxxer all my children
are completely vaccinated by the way I'm
not sure that I would now do that they
talking about lying and what the left
has done to Medicine
that in you know that in California now
as as of last week in California a
doctor who says things that the AMA or
the or the California medical
association differ with can lose his or
her license to practice medicine doctors
are not free in California to speak out
on medical issues if if Pfizer that's
really what it means if Pfizer doesn't
agree with them I I mean the the level
of corruption
masking kids at two years of age first
of all I think you're an idiot if you
mask yourself at 52 years of age but
that that's that's that is beside the
point by the two-year-old
we have hurt children and the and the
the children's hospitals that that allow
surgeons to remove healthy girls breasts
if they say they're boys
did you hear the latest story it was
just what was it yesterday I reported
where was it outside of San Diego
uh a um in the the girls locker room a a
a a male shows his genitalia in the
showers the 17 year old says you know I
don't I don't want to see I don't want
to see it I don't want my little sister
to see this
but they say sorry this was at the YMCA
once called the Young Men's children
Association did you get you got it you
guys are fast 17 Rob G year old scolded
for crying over transgender woman's
penis and YMCA look she's she's scolded
this 17 year old is scolded this is the
girl speaking yes this is the girl
speaking that's exactly right
it was changing after swimming one day
last month at the Santee YMCA when she
spotted a naked trans woman in the
changing rooms
so here's the story you get it this is
the sick World we're living if you show
your penis to young girls you are
arrested but if you show your penis to
young girls and say you're a female
you're rewarded
and protected clown World protected
rewarded uh and and the and the girl who
objects is the one who's punished so let
me let me ask you're intolerant that's
right let me let me ask this question so
to me logically
that that can't make sense to anybody
right logically so so Dennis how much of
this creating momentum has to do that
the one percent are so much louder than
the other 99 who are just saying it's
not a big deal let it go well what you
have is the usual phenomenon
cowardice is the human Norm again human
nature is not basically good most people
including me our nature is to be a
coward
I've had to fight that and I'm not I'm
not a coward that that I can say
categorically uh but you have to fight
it the natural inclination in life is to
be afraid afraid of of being disliked
afraid of being ostracized afraid of
being fired afraid of being shut down
afraid of whatever it is that's one of
another reason why uh the only answer to
all of this is the judeo-christian code
which says you fear God you don't fear
man
the the only out in not fearing human
beings is essentially fearing God and
it's it's a basic uh biblical principle
but uh that's what it is
people are afraid uh to uh to why do the
girls at the University of Pennsylvania
a swim team why did they continue to
compete when the when this guy who said
he's a girl uh went from male swimming
where he was a nothing to female
swimming where he was a champion he
deprived all these girls of of winning
uh races uh because he said he was a
girl
and uh and every one of the girls had to
go along with this knowing they were
being cheated uh by by a man who says
he's a woman they were cheated the guys
that cheat or the woman's a cheat code
or whatever call him her whatever you
want is a cheat and the New York Times
supports cheating the New York Times The
Washington Post CNN they they're they
are morally awful uh uh uh vehicles for
lying to the public and so here is the
question why did the girls compete if
every girl on the team said were not
racing it would have ended this fraud of
having men compete in women's sports
but they won't they're afraid because if
they do that the University of
Pennsylvania threatened them
they you know we will come down they may
have been evicted from the University
but they wouldn't have kicked out a
whole team but the girls understandably
were afraid they'll be called
transphobes you don't want to be called
a transphobe right of course not New
York Times will call you a transphobe if
the girls decided not to race the New
York Times that sick editorial page of
the New York Times would have said
they're transphobic girls which label
right now is the is is the biggest
career ending label one can get
a racist homophobe transphob I mean by
the way do you ever notice isn't it
interesting there's a word for Jew
hatred anti-Semitism there's a word for
Muslim hatred islamophobe why isn't
there a word for Christian hatred
because the left makes up our vocabulary
the most hated group the most hated
religious group on Earth today are
Christians they're certainly the most
killed and I'm a Jew saying this
there's no word for nobody hates
Christians uh if you show a picture of
Muhammad a painting of Muhammad not a
cartoon a Muslim painting of Muhammad
just done in Hamlin University looked
that one up h-a-m-l-i-n-e but the the
art Professor who taught the corset I'm
telling you in advance I'm putting up a
an ancient uh rendition of Muhammad if
if you are offended by it you may not
want to watch and she was kicked out of
Hamlin University she's an art professor
she showed she showed the piece or
Charlie oh wait but but yet or well that
that was that they were murdered yes so
yeah there it is Hamilton is fired over
medieval painting done by Muslims you
can't show a Muslim painting of zoom in
for the picture so we can see what the
picture is yeah there it is well this is
because thou shall not create any
caricature painting or image yeah but
that's not in the Quran that's that some
Muslims believe that later Muslims they
obviously medieval Muslims didn't
believe that they did make paintings of
of Muhammad but anyway
crucifix my own the reason I raise it
there is there there's a famous uh
quote-unquote artwork piss Christ
which toward put that one up oh yeah
that that toward the American museums
it's a jar of urine with this the guy
a a crucifix in his own urine and it
went all around the country did
nobody's afraid of Christians The Book
of Mormon it's a book of Broadway
nobody's afraid of Mormons of course
that they're afraid of Muslims because
cowardice is a central tenet of of
leftism back to Pat's question of what's
what is the worst label to have is there
one that's worse than no no
anti-semitic with Kanye that's that's
yeah
they're they're all tied for first
however they can dismiss you they'll
they'll uh they'll just use the term I
don't know why why people will be racist
though right if you were able to racist
or yeah you were done right but every
white is racist so therefore there's no
such thing as racism as soon as you say
every you have ended the issue
that's right it's but by the way it's
such a joke
here I am I'm I'm your I'm the uh Dei uh
head at the University diversity equity
and inclusion and I'm telling you every
white is racist
so obviously they're speaking
autobiographically are they not hello
I'm a racist and you should trust me
I don't quite follow that anyway it's
just that's another great lie for the
record I don't have a racist bone in my
body I don't give a damn about your
color
simple as that
but but that is now called racist did
you know look up that you you University
of California list of microaggressions
if you say colorblind you're a racist
colorblind is a racist
yes
if you say there is only one race the
human race that is considered racist by
the University of California you were
how old when MLK was there this
colorblind and stuff so I would have
been uh what was that 68 yeah yeah so I
would have been 19 years old yeah yeah
everything he I assumed that was when
you're going through a major situation
in your life you're in college you're
learning you're seeing well no all these
assassinations were I I I I didn't
understand what was happening to my
beloved America I I have to admit it was
it was disconcerting obviously so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]